hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
there are a few interesting puzzles
raised by the topics of knowledge a
piston may in Greek and perception I say
Sisson in Greek in Aristotle's
categories chapter 7 where he is
discussing the category of relation the
Proust II that the the things or the
terms that exist or have their their
intelligibility in relation to something
else or from from their relation with
something else now why do these puzzles
arise the first of them happens when he
is talking about correlative terms and
he suggests that you know we tend to
think that when it comes to these Co
relative terms these terms that are
understood in relation to each other
they they denote things that come into
being at the same time like father and
son you know a father is a human being
well let's say we're not talking about
other animals right so we've got a human
being but he's not a father until he
actually has a child it doesn't have to
be a son could be a daughter of course
right but the some sort of child so you
know parent and child come into
existence as such at the same time
Aristotle says there's an exception to
this and the exception would be
something like knowledge or similarly
perception why is that well because the
knowledge of something and I've got this
of here capitalized to note that we're
talking about a relative term knowledge
of whatever it happens to be knowledge
of chalk all right and its properties
and its relations to each other
oops like the fact that it'll fall if
you're not careful with it
perception likewise you know we can
perceive the chalk you're perceiving it
right here on the blackboard through
your visuals
you you could be I suppose you know
hearing it as it clinks on the
chalkboard as well you can't really feel
it through the camera or smell it we
don't have anything like smellivision
but you get the point with perception
right these these can exist but they're
dependent on something else and so like
aerosol is going to say they're
dependent on some sort of object of
knowledge or perception and that object
can predate them as a matter of fact you
could have well let's take a book right
you could have this book existing
imagine everybody dies of a plague right
and this book is sitting there waiting
for some alien civilization to come and
discover it and let's say that they
actually you know can read English and
in ancient Greek on the facing pages and
you know they've got all the things for
that well they would be ready to have
knowledge of what's it contained in this
book likewise they could perceive the
the letters they wouldn't even need to
be able to read it right they could
perceive these squiggly black marks on
the white thing but if there's nobody to
actually do the knowing or perceiving
then you just have something that is
knowable or is perceivable and it exists
right so I can proceed it and it can
exist without knowledge or perception
you know close the book put it away I'm
going to throw it down the stairs throw
it down the trash chute you know it
still exists regardless of whether I
have access to it or not so he says it
seems that the object of knowledge is
prior to it exist before knowledge we
gain knowledge
Aristotle points us out generally
speaking of things that already exist
and you know he doesn't go into this but
it's interesting to consider this as
well we gain knowledge typically us the
kinds of people that we are not just of
things that we encounter for the very
first time we might say that her
perception but knowledge a lot of our
knowledge is actually gained from
somebody else telling us here here's
some knowledge we're passing this on to
you
I mean classes lectures all this this
sort of stuff Aristotle's whole corpus
is is knowledge presumably and he is
providing it to us and then we take it
in right so it was around before us so
the knowledge is a relative term and the
knowledge would be say of what Aristotle
is teaching here that would be the other
core relative term so he goes on and he
says in very few cases are none can our
knowledge have come into being along
with its own proper object most of the
time that we come to know something to
have knowledge about it it's at the end
of a process where we had to learn it
and what we're learning about existed
prior to our knowing it so he says take
away the object of knowledge or
perception he's going to say this as
well and the knowledge is removed it's
canceled out take away the thing that's
actually being known there's no more
knowledge so he says if the object no
longer exists there can no longer be any
knowledge there being now nothing to
know and we might get you know a little
bit technical about this and say well
what is it what does he have in mind
here well if we talk about states of
affairs that we know to be the case that
makes a good a lot of sense if we take
those away we no longer know those to be
the case for instance a statement like
it is day right now when I'm filming
this it's actually dark but perhaps when
you're watching this it's it's now light
wherever you happen to be so you're like
yes it is day well you know how do you
have knowledge that it's night or it's
day well you may say well you'll go and
find a window and look out or walk
around and that would be quite true
you know the statement expressing the
knowledge sometimes it's the case
sometimes it's not when it's no longer
day you don't know that it's day that
doesn't satisfy all that much this is
admittedly
a place where it starts to get a bit
murky in Aristotle's categories and
raise some some questions and problems
we'll come back to those in a moment
so he goes on and he says you can say
the same thing about perception the
object he says would be prior to the act
of perception suppose you cancel out the
perceptible you cancel the perception as
well I think that one makes a lot more
sense you could bring up cases and say
well wait a second what if I'm
hallucinating and I think that I'm
perceiving something that's not actually
there Aristotle would say well there you
go
you think that you perceive something
that's not actually there you're not
actually having perception as such
because perception is of something so
the way that he's using perception there
it would seem to answer that problem he
says the act of perception involves or
you know or implies first a body
perceived and then a body in which it
takes place so if you remove the
perceptible body itself is removed for
the body itself is perceptible body not
being existent perception must cease to
exist so take away the perceptible and
you take away the perception but taking
away the perception itself doesn't
necessarily negate the objects again
let's use the example here Green Book
right I'm perceiving it now it's behind
my back okay I am perceiving it because
I you know I'm feeling it so let's let's
put it put it down somewhere right now
I'm not seeing it
not touching it my other senses aren't
involved it's still there
it still exists right I haven't done a
magic trick and made a poof vanish and
go away it's still there waiting to be
Percy
should I turn myself around and aha
there's my my book right but I'm not
currently perceiving it when that
happens so the perceptible can exist
sometimes before the perception or after
the perception of it no longer exists
but now it's not not being treated
really as a a relative isn't it's been
just be treating it as an object which
then could be perceived potentially so
like I put here strictly speaking both
of these knowledge and perception are of
something some sort of object and
they're also in or by something else
namely the know were or the perceiver
right this is a classic example we think
back to categories 2 with chapter 2
where Aristotle is distinguishing
between what's predicated of a subject
and what's in a subject he talks about
knowledge as being in a subject that is
in the mind right but it's knowledge of
something so long as we're thinking
about it in terms of relation the last
thing that I want to say about this that
is particularly interesting and that
probably raises some puzzles that I
think people may not be entirely
satisfied with Aristotle Streetman
because it's not really telling you much
about it is this at the very end of
chapter 7 he starts talking more about
knowledge and he tells us that knowledge
can be of correlative terms or things
how does he talk about that well here
here's what he says if a relative is
definitely known right there's knowledge
of it then that to which it is relative
also will be as definitely know so if we
use the examples that he has he actually
says this is you know pretty
self-evident if we know a particular
thing to be relative relatives being
those things whose very existence
consists in their being in some way
related to some other thing you know
what that other thing is to which that
thing is related you know child you know
parent
you may not know you know what color the
parents here is that there's something
like that but if you know that there's a
child and you know that that is a child
you know there has to be a parent
because that car relative term doesn't
mean the parent actually exists but you
know there has to been a parent if we're
using the concept and the term child
similarly if we if we call something
double and and you say well double what
double you know the size double the
duration once we actually have that
other term now it's all completely clear
we have knowledge of that so knowledge
is not just of a object knowledge can be
of the relation between different things
as well he has another great example
here that I love if you definitely know
a particular thing is more beautiful at
once must you definitely know that than
which it is reckoned more beautiful it
doesn't make sense let's say we take an
animal right and weird you know at the
cat show or something like that and you
know for those of you go to those sorts
of things my example may be totally
off-base because I only judge by the
little snippets that I've seen on TV and
YouTube videos that I've had to watch on
occasion about this this sort of thing
it's not not really my cup of tea but as
far as I understand it
judges say well this cat is more
beautiful than this cat they even assign
numbers based on things now again I have
no clue maybe it's based on their fur
and their how their eyes look and how
their ears are you know whether they're
clean or how their nails are whoo you
know we don't don't worry about those
particulars but if we're saying that
this is more beautiful more beautiful
than what than all these other cats or
this cat is more beautiful than that cat
or this cat is more beautiful than the
painting of that cat hanging in the
study we use these terms correlative Li
and we can have knowledge of these Co
relatives not just the knowledge of the
thing relation
in relation to it right the object of
the knowledge but knowledge of how two
different things are in fact related to
each other